good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight there was a lot going on
right around the time of the last
presidential inauguration so you may
have missed that on his very first day
as president joe biden ordered federal
law enforcement and intelligence
agencies to prepare a review of how the
administration should fight terrorism by
last june that report was complete it
concluded that after more than 20 years
islamic terror is no longer the greatest
threat to this country
instead the agencies declared that
domestic political extremism is quote
the most urgent terrorism threat the
united states faces today
that's a very stark assessment so you
have to ask who exactly are these
terrorists who threaten us so urgently
and they're not who you might expect
the report did not even mention the blm
riots the deadly element riots that had
just taken place there wasn't a word
about antifa there was nothing about the
gunman who murdered 800 americans in the
city of chicago last year many of them
children no they weren't there
instead the bide administration declared
that the quote most lethal elements of
today's domestic terror threat
are political conservatives they're
people who disagree with joe biden
now that report was released almost
exactly six months ago six months ago
this friday it received relatively
little attention and hasn't since
and no major news organization even
asked the most obvious question these
terrorists who threaten us where are
they
if trump voters are really the most
lethal threat that our country faces
today
where are all the people they've killed
that's not an easy question to answer
just look at the numbers which are
fairly tidally kept
take a look at all the americans who
died by violence over the past 12 months
and there are many thousands and
thousands of americans and ask a simple
question how many of them were killed by
right-wingers for political reasons
not many
or since we're talking about threats
here pose the question another way are
you more in danger walking through a
neighborhood that votes 90 democrat
or a neighborhood that votes 90
republican
come on
this claim is ridiculous on its face
there is no substantial right-wing
terror threat in this country certainly
not in relative terms there just isn't
and no one's shown there is
the white house knows this of course
they can read the numbers as well as
anyone else can so they're working hard
to create the illusion of that threat
much hangs on their ability to do that
you may remember the story this fall
about a group called the national school
boards association which sent a letter
to the feds asking the doj to take a
look at parents who don't like their
kids curriculums well the just
department responded immediately to that
letter talk about customer service
days later the attorney general
announced the fbi would investigate moms
who dared to complain at school board
meetings as potential terrorists
many people were shocked by this story
but we just learned it's worse even than
we thought it was a new freedom of
information act request has revealed
that the national school boards
association asked the feds to
investigate parents because the feds
asked them to ask the feds to
investigate parents
see how that works
apparently the secretary of education
miguel cardona told school board
administrators to write their letter to
the white house the white house then
used that letter as a pretext to begin a
crackdown on parents
see how that works the snake eating its
tail
when you don't have enough domestic
terrorists to justify a political purge
then you just go ahead and create them
and that's exactly what they've been
doing
this week the campaign against this new
american al-qaeda entered a new and very
ominous phase again little noticed by
the national media this tuesday two days
ago the doj announced the creation of a
new domestic terrorism unit what will it
do
well it will target quote anti-authority
ideologues anti-authority audio logs now
keep in mind this country was founded by
people who are anti-authority ideologues
that's why they created america and
baked the idea of opposing authority so
it doesn't get too big and take over
your life into our founding documents
these ideas are central to the american
idea in fact they are the american idea
but in this administration they are now
crimes here's matt olson the assistant
attorney general explaining
we face an elevated threat from domestic
violent extremists
that is individuals in the united states
who seek to commit violent criminal acts
in furtherance of domestic social or
political goals
domestic violence extremists are often
motivated by a mix of ideologies and
personal grievances
we've seen a growing threat from those
who are motivated by racial animus
as well as those who ascribe to
extremist anti-government and
anti-authority ideologies i've decided
to establish a domestic terrorism unit
to augment our existing approach
this group of dedicated attorneys will
focus on the domestic terrorism threat
who's the threat to the country that guy
is the threat to the country and the
people working for him and those
propping him up
and the people
spreading the core lie here which is
that american citizens who distrust the
government or don't like its policies
are terrorists just today on msnbc jason
johnson one of its contributors
described the entire republican party as
a terrorist organization
so you can see where this is going again
and we're quoting now this is the
assistant attorney general we have seen
a growing threat from those who
subscribe to anti-government and
anti-authority ideologies
really is that threat growing
is it true let's see here that threat is
being used to justify the creation of
this agency but it's not rooted in
reality 27 years ago back in 1995 you'll
remember 168 people were murdered in the
oklahoma city bombing another 700 were
injured now the investigation into what
happened that day involved nearly thirty
thousand interviews investigators
gathered seven pounds seven thousand
pounds of evidence we could go on
it was an enormous investigation
attorney general merrick garland by the
way was part of it at the time
here's the point despite the size of
that investigation no one
suggested even hinted that we might need
to create a new domestic terror division
within the doj to handle the problem no
the whole thing was handled by fbi field
offices as things like this had been for
many decades the fbi field officers did
their jobs the man accused of doing it
got the death penalty and you may have
noticed it didn't happen again
and then joe biden became president
and the number of so-called domestic
terror investigations more than doubled
so the question is what exactly are they
investigating if there's no substantial
death toll from these terrorists in our
midst
what exactly are the feds looking into
well they're taking a close look at
crimes like the plot to kidnap michigan
governor gretchen whitmer
a plot that helped her political
fortunes considerably would it consist
of well that conspiracy in the end
turned out to have more fbi agents and
informants involved than would-be
kidnappers the guy the fed said were
running it turned out to be homeless he
was living in the basement of a vacuum
repair shop his friends called him
captain autism
and they called him that for a reason
he wasn't the ringleader of anything he
couldn't have been the whole thing was
ridiculous
but it stoked the story line it was
politically expedient and so the media
uncritically promoted it again and again
as if it were real the media's job by
the way to remind you is to push back
against government statements to find
out if they're actually true because it
turns out politicians may say things for
political reasons and it's the media's
job to discern truth from spin
the media's job is not to act as
spokesmen for the people in power
and yet that's what they're doing
now the doj in case you haven't noticed
has decided that the january 6th
protesters are the real terrorists
they're the insurrectionists you keep
hearing about and yet weirdly as of just
two days two days ago not one american
citizen had actually been charged by the
federal government with insurrecting
watch them admit that
has anyone been charged with the crime
of insurrection
following january 6
i am not aware that anyone has been
charged with that that particular
offense even if it is a an offense i i
just am not aware of that
oops
they can't actually be insurrectionist
if no one has committed insurrection
that's pretty embarrassing apparently
the doj finally realized how
embarrassing it was so about 48 hours
after the testimony you just saw and
more than a year after january 6th today
the feds announced that they will charge
someone with sedition after all
now if you've got any questions about
the timing of these charges or the merit
of the sedition case the doj just
announced the byte administration would
like to remind you to keep those
questions to yourself
and just to make certain you do keep
them to yourself or unable to share them
with anyone else today joe biden also
announced a crackdown on the news media
as he put it a crackdown on anyone who
spreads quote disinformation and
misinformation about his government
watch
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
the misinformation that's on your shows
yeah message received it has to stop joe
biden says
so that means that big tech and media
organizations have to do what he says
just like his vax mandate found
unconstitutional today by the way it'll
still be enforced because
big businesses rely on the government to
exist they take government money they
are regulated from the very top to the
very bottom by the government so it
takes a lot to defy the president of the
united states if he tells you to do
something you'd better do it what joe
biden is telling media companies to do
today is to censor their content so it
doesn't contradict
his decrees
now cnn has no problem with this in fact
they made fun of what joe biden said
today they made fun of his call for
censorship not because it's obviously
unconstitutional which it is but because
it wasn't quite fascist enough
one of those weird-looking media
reporters over at cnn wrote this quote
i'm sure the murdochs will get right on
this now that this special appeal has
been made exclamation point
so they understand exactly what's going
on here joe biden is targeting fox news
for censorship
his call for censorship by the way
comes after hundreds of doctors and
scientists called on spotify to adopt a
misinformation policy that would shut
down joe rogan's podcast rogan recovered
from covet without the facts and they
hate him for it
so it's not just the government of
course
it's people acting on behalf of the
government calling for the same thing
which is censorship of political
opinions
what you're seeing here is dangerous
there's no other way to describe it far
more dangerous than domestic terror
threat they've been bloviating about for
the last three days it contravenes the
first amendment under the first
amendment the government cannot
coordinate with private actors to censor
free speech period the supreme court has
made that very clear over centuries
and yet that's exactly what's happening
joe biden did it today care to complain
about that
probably not you may have noticed what
happens to people who complain too much
roger stone for example complained an
awful lot about the government he did it
loudly often he did it for years and the
doj didn't like it so in the end they
accused roger stone in the base of zero
evidence whatsoever of colluding with
russia
in the end they charged him with lying
to congress something that happens
literally every day of the year but in
his case they made it a felony
threatened to send him to prison for the
rest of his life in the meantime they
sent a helicopter a boat an armed
paramilitaries to his home at dawn after
coordinating the raid with cnn
really one of the darkest moments
in civil liberties in recent history we
still have the tape let's watch it again
exclusive footage you're looking at
right now from cnn as the fbi arrives at
roger stone's residence in fort
lauderdale florida
taking him into custody they arrived
before dawn there before 6a or just
after 6am a dozen officers were told
so they coordinate
with cnn just to make sure it's all
preserved on tape to send the message to
everybody else for the encouragement of
the others as the french used to say
and then they send guys with automatic
weapons to your house to shut you up to
destroy you
now the people who ordered that rage
should have been brought up on charges
themselves
but they weren't they're promoted and
now thanks to joe biden they have more
power to harass their political enemies
do you feel safer hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else